you look very sexy I'm trying so hard
it's like I thought you have to I'm
single so you like have to look hot all
the time is that no see I've been
married a long time and I have never
felt in me to be hot that part and first
of all when I was single I didn't feel
that need but now for you you think I
you don't need it and like even when
you're single as a guy your personality
is enough as a woman your personality is
just like it's it's it's an afterthought
you need to just lead with looks
oh I'm reading all these books about how
to trick a man into loving you and that
is that is such an unhealthy field of
books yeah I am know they work do
they're working for my friends and
they're you know they're like why men
love [ __ ] I didn't read that one but
I just started like yelling at baristas
more and working for you and then
there's some there's one I'm reading
right now called fake it till you kill
yourself and I can't wait to finish it
because all these books tell you they're
like sorry girls but your personality
like stop working on it it doesn't
matter like you have to look you have to
look bangable all the time like remind
men that they want to put their penises
and you even at like the bank like you
have to direct like you should just bend
over like 'hey i should just be in line
at the bank like this like presenting
all the time to men to remind them that
they can have sex with you and it's
exhausting and it sucks but I understand
it's tough on the low back - I would
think this whole area constantly
constantly presenting is just doing
anything for you right now
not doing it yes you're right like and
there's a way to stand as a woman to
where you can just be like way hotter I
have learned this when I was on Dancing
with the Stars cuz I just have bad
posture I'm always just like and if you
stand if you try to make yourself a
centaur like it's hurting so bad but
everyone in here wants to you will be
more attractive to men it's exhausting
it hurts so bad and that's the thing I'm
just like I'm so tired of being a woman
I have to be honest with you like
exhausting it is so exhausting Conan I
got a sense of what it's like to be a
man when I played Kurt Cobain on this
show called historical roast I talked
about it last time oh yeah yeah and you
dressed up like Kurt Cobain and you
looked a lot like Kurt Cobain yeah it
was like I was a dude for the night it
was awesome I got I got paid more I
didn't see that coming like I was
manspreading because I just felt like
that was the way to do it I can't do it
in this dress now but you know what it's
like you you like and God and women get
mad at men when they do it cuz we're
like they're taking up space it's like
isn't it enough for you but it's really
about their balls like I feel like it's
like it's about your balls and like
you're giving your balls room and I
understand that however we have stuff to
air out - I've got an accordion that
needs to be
like air it out yeah yeah so why don't
we have to be all bunchy and you guys I
mean I know it gets wet down there for
you but it's so it can sweat for us down
there too and yours is cuz you don't
wipe well enough - cuz I walked by a guy
who was walking his dog and he said good
girl and now I'm saturated the rest of
the day
this is just whenever the I have in
moments like this it's like call Boston
and tow don't let mom watch this show I
love that Nikki Glaser plays the
accordion